oh my God
cardi B and her hubby offset almost
missed Super Bowl 57. just made it on
time
[Applause]
as for why well the rappers dangerously
High pumps the same shoes that we fit
the same shoes yeah blame it on Cardi's
stilettos that slowed her down on her
way to the big game the couple is
hustling and shuffling toward the
stadium naturally the moment went viral
oh my God
Carly's bubblegum pink Christian
Louboutin platforms come with a hefty
price tag twelve hundred bucks but this
is the Super Bowl and cardi had to bring
her a game to the big game
[Music]
despite the struggle the two eventually
got there well we just made it on time
we
took we just made it on time
just made it on time yeah cardi gave
fans a glance of riri's show-stopping
performance from her Suite
look
[Applause]
an offset he had the time of his life
[Music]
want to get it right you know
everybody's watching Guardian offset
also took the stage Super Bowl weekend
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the couple headlined a pre-party
Saturday night and of course showed off
a whole lot of PDA
[Music]
which reminds us of yet another moment
that got fans talking just last weekend
at Clive Davis's pre-grammies party
whether they're swapping spit on music's
biggest night or racing to make it to
the Super Bowl before kickoff
oh my God
this is one couple that never drops the
ball
[Music]